♪
>> Tucker: ANOTHER
INSTALLMENT TONIGHT IN OUR
SERIES DRUGGED THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC IS THE WORST DRUG
CRISIS IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY, EVERY YEAR
DRUG OVERDOSES KILL MORE
PEOPLE IN THE ENTIRE VIETNAM
WAR AND VAST MAJORITY OF
THOSE ARE CAUSED BY OPIOIDS
AS YOU KNOW BY NOW.
TWIST PAST DRUG OVERDOSES
CAUSED BY AMERICAN MEDICINE.
HUGE QUANTITIES OF OPIOID
PAINKILLERS ARE PRESCRIBED
EVERY YEAR AND CREATED
MILLIONS OF ADDICTS U NOT
EVERYONE IS CONVINCED
OPIOIDS IS TO BLAME.
DOCTOR, THANKS FOR COMING
ON, I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING MOO,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: AT THE VERY
INFANT STAGES OF THE CURRENT
DISASTER, THIS EPIDEMIC,
YOUR ORGANIZATION, ALONG
WITH ANOTHER RELEASED A
STATEMENT AND I JUST WANT TO
GET YOUR TAKE ON IT NOW 21
YEARS LATER.
AND I'M QUOTING STUDIES
INDICATE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ADDICTION
WHEN OPIOIDS ARE USED FOR
THE RELIEF OF PAIN IS LOW.
FURTHERMORE EXPERIENCE HAS
SHOWN THAT KNOWN ADDICTS CAN
BENEFIT FROM THE CAREFULLY
JUDICIOUS USE OF OPIOID.
IN LIGHT OF EVERYTHING WE
HAVE SEEN OVER THE LAST 21
YEARS, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT STATEMENT.
>> I THINK WE HAVE LEARNED A
LOT OVER THE LAST 20 YEARS
AROUND PAIN MANAGEMENT.
GOING BACK TO THAT
TREATMENT, IT WAS STATED
THAT THE RISK FOR ADDICTION
WAS LOW.
I THINK OVER TIME WE HAVE
SEEN THAT THERE IS A RISK
FOR ADDICTION WITH PATIENTS
AND STILL A PROBLEM.
BUT, USING MEDICATIONS WITH
THE WRONG PATIENTS, THE
DEVELOPMENT ADDICTION
PROBLEM OR MISUSING THE
MEDICINE CAN LEAD TO ALL
SORTS OF PROBLEMS.
SHOWN THAT THE RISK OF
ADDICTION FROM STARTING WITH
PAIN SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEM
IS AT LEAST 10% OR LITTLE
HIGHER THAN THAT IT'S LOW
BUT STILL SIGNIFICANT.
WE REALLY NEED TO BE CAREFUL
WHO GETS THESE MID SINS AND
DECIDING IF THESE ARE
EFFECTIVE THERAPIES.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT, TUCKER,
PAIN MANAGEMENT ISN'T.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
>> OTHER OPTIONS FOR OUR
PATIENTS.
>> Tucker: TAKE THREE STEPS
BACK PHYSICIANS ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY TRUSTED BY
PEOPLE OR TRAINED TO TRUST
THEM.
THEIR JOB IS TO HEAL US.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: BASICALLY TELLING
PEOPLE TO TAKE MORE OPIOIDS
AND NOW WE HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DEAD AND WHOLE
COMMUNITIES DESTROYED AND
THE MIDDLE CLASS LIFE
EXPECTANCY LITERALLY
SHRINKING BECAUSE YOU HAVE
THIS OH, SORRY, WE WERE
WRONG.
WOULDN'T A MORE FUNCTIONAL
SOCIETY PUNISH PEOPLE WHO
SAID SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
>> I THINK THOUGH THE FOCUS
SHOULD OBVIOUSLY BE ON HOW
DO WE ASSESS WHO WHAT IS
EFFECTIVE FOR THIS
TREATMENT.
WHAT TYPES OF TREATMENT
COULD THEY BENEFIT FROM.
SO MANY OTHER OPTIONS FOR
PATIENTS U AND MAYBE A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF PATIENTS NEED
TO BE ON OPIOIDS AS PART OF
THEIR TREATMENT PLAN.
I'M NOT SURE ACCUSE HOG IS
WRONG OR RIGHT.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE ALL
KINDS OF MISTAKES THAT
PEOPLE MAKE AND MOST OF THEM
ARE IN GOOD FAITH INDUSTRY
THAT MAKES THE PRODUCT USING
PHYSICIANS AND THE PUBLIC TO
USE MORE OF THE PRODUCT,
THEN I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SUSPECT THERE IS A FINANCIAL
MOTIVATION AND I DON'T WANT
TO BE A LEFTY ABOUT IT AND I
DON'T WANT TO USE THE PHRASE
GREED IS KILLING PEOPLE.
BUT IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE
THAT A LITTLE BIT.
IF YOU SEE WHAT I MEAN.
>> AGAIN, I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
WHAT A PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANY MIGHT DO.
I WOULD HOPE THEY WOULD WORK
IN THE INTEREST OF THE
PATIENT.
AGAIN, I REALLY THINK THE
DISCUSSION SHOULD BE ON HOW
DO WE ASSESS PATIENTS FOR
PAIN MANAGEMENT AND
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE THESE
OTHER TREATMENTS FOR THOSE
PATIENTS.
IF THEY DO DEVELOP AN
ADDICTION PROBLEM, WHAT ARE
THE RESOURCES FOR THOSE
PATIENTS.
I THINK REALLY WE NEED TO
EXPAND OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
PAIN MANAGEMENT AND DEAL
WITH PATIENTS ARE SUFFERING
MILLIONS OF PATIENTS WITH
CHRONIC PAGE.
AND THEY NEED TO HAVE PAIN
TREATED EFFECTIVELY.
I'M NOT IMPLYING THAT THEY
ALL NEED TO BE ON OPIOIDS.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT DONE TO
RADIO KIND OF DECIDE AND
STRATIFYING PATIENTS,
DECIDING WHICH PATIENTS ARE
AT RISK AND WHICH AREN'T.
MONITOR PATIENTS BETTER AND
HOPEFULLY THAT'S WHERE
MEDICINE IS GOING AND AT
LEAST THAT WILL HELP FROM
THE PRESCRIPTION SIDE SEE A
REDUCTION IN THE DEATHS
RELATED TO OPIOID
PRESCRIPTIONS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, I WONDER
WHAT YOU THOUGHT OVER THE
PAST 15 YEARS WHAT THE
MANUFACTURERS THOUGHT WHEN
THEY SAW IT OF COURSE THEY
KNOW WHERE THEIR PRODUCT
GOES THEY DID SEE IT THERE
WERE COUNTIES IN WEST
VIRGINIA AND KENTUCKY THAT
WERE GETTING BY A FACTOR OF
LET'S SAY 10 MORE OPIOID
DOSES THAN THEY HAD PEOPLE.
WILDLY DISPROPORTIONATE TO
ANY CONVENTIONAL HUMAN NEED.
CLEARLY THAT'S FEEDING A
ADDICTION U SOCIAL DISASTER
U AND THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT WHERE WERE
YOU WHEN THAT WAS HAPPENING.
>> I CAN'T SAY WHAT WAS DONE
IN SMALLER COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT THERE WAS
IN SOME CASES
DIVERSIFICATION OF
MEDICINES, THERE WERE PILL
MILLS, PHYSICIANS OR BAD
APPLES WERE PRESCRIBING
KNOWINGLY THESE MEDICINES
WERE GOING TO BE ABUSED AND
MISUSED.
I CAN'T SUPPORT OF ANY OF
THAT.
>> Tucker: IT WAS YOUR GROUP
TO HELP CONVINCE PHYSICIANS
TO BE LOOSER IN PRESCRIPTION
OF OPIOIDS.
GOTTEN EXTREMELY RICH ON THE
FORBES LIST BECAUSE OF IT.
THEY KNEW THIS WAS HAPPENING
AND DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY.
>> I THINK I WOULD MAYBE
CORRECT THAT AND S. THAT OUR
GROUP, PAIN MEDICINE AND
OTHER PAIN ASSOCIATIONS AND
PHYSICIAN GROUPS, THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING, YOU
KNOW, APPROPRIATE MANAGEMENT
OF CHRONIC PAIN.
AND, AGAIN, WHETHER THAT
INCLUDES OPIOIDS OR NOT.
OUR GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO
ASSESS PATIENTS.
THERE IS A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
PHYSICIANS CAN USE TO, YOU
KNOW, HELP MONITOR PATIENTS
TO SEE IF THEY ARE TAKING
THEIR MEDICINES EFFECTIVELY.
>> Tucker: I GET IT.
IF YOU ARE SUGGESTING THAT
PEOPLE USE OPIOIDS IN WAYS
THAT THEY DIDN'T BEFORE.
THAT'S WHAT THE STATEMENT WE
READ SUGGESTS.
ISN'T IT INCUMBENT ON TO YOU
SEE HOW THAT TURNS OUT.
YOU SEE LIKE MASSIVE AMOUNTS
OF HYDROCODONE GOING TO SOME
PHARMACY IN FLORIDA OR
WHEELING, WEST VIRGINIA,
DON'T YOU GET ON THE PHONE
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND SAY WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG
HERE BUT NO ONE DID THAT.
>> YEAH, TUCKER, I'M NOT
SURE WHAT HAPPENED AT THE
FEDERAL OR STATE LEVEL TO BE
MORE AWARE OF THIS CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THAT WAS GOING ON
AROUND THAT AGAIN, OUR FOCUS
WAS REALLY AND HAS BEEN TO
REALLY PUSH FOR BETTER